Trascrizione: Alessandra Ghilardini
Revisore: Michele Gianella
30 anni fa,
io vivevo con i miei genitori
in una casa in campagna
e quello che mi è rimasto
impresso di quel periodo
è che quando si usciva di casa
non si aveva una particolare apprensione
nel controllare che le porte
fossero chiuse,
si viveva in un clima
di piena tranquillità e fiducia.
Oggi, però,
se io ripenso a quel periodo
mi vengono i brividi:
io non uscirei mai di casa
se non ho controllato
che tutte le finestre sono chiuse,
ho chiuso a tripla mandata
il portoncino blindato,
ho attivato il sistema d'allarme.
Questo perché ho ben chiaro
quali sono i rischi
di lasciare una casa incustodita.
Ecco, questa maggiore sensibilità
non c'è stata nell'informatica:
io ogni giorno trovo persone
che si lamentano perché devono
cambiare la password,
perché è troppo lunga,
perché è troppo complicata,
perché non basta più la password
ma arriva un codice,
via sms sul telefonino.
Eppure, tutte queste misure
sono state fatte
per permettere di proteggerci,
per rendere più sicura
la nostra vita digitale,
però noi non ce ne rendiamo conto,
perché non abbiamo chiari quali siano
i rischi a cui andiamo incontro.
Viviamo la nostra vita digitale
in maniera un po’ naif,
come vivevo io 30 anni fa,
lasciando la porta aperta.
Però questa porta non è più
la porta di 30 anni fa:
innanzitutto sono tante porte,
una per ogni dispositivo che uso
per vivere la mia vita digitale.
Lo smartphone, il tablet, il computer,
sono porte che non danno
nel quartiere di 30 anni fa,
dove ci si conosceva tutti,
ma danno in un mondo, quello digitale,
che non ha confini.
Un mondo dove ogni persona che ne fa parte
potrebbe voler entrare
nella mia casa digitale.
Più la tecnologia
è diventata di uso comune,
è entrata nelle nostre vite,
nel quotidiano,
più determinate azioni
che facevamo nella vita reale
abbiamo iniziato a farle
nella vita digitale.
Noi arriviamo a casa la sera,
ci sediamo nel divano,
prendiamo lo smartphone o il tablet
e facciamo un bonifico,
magari per pagare l'affitto,
ordiniamo del cibo online,
compriamo qualcosa per la casa su Amazon.
Tutte cose che, nella nostra vita reale,
avremmo fatto insieme
ad un professionista,
una persona come magari
il cassiere della Banca,
il commesso o il cameriere,
che comunque sanno bene cosa devono fare,
come lo devono fare
e a cosa devono stare attenti.
Noi invece, giocoforza,
non siamo preparati, non lo sappiamo.
Poi sottovalutiamo i rischi
che non conosciamo
e a volte addirittura
li amplifichiamo noi stessi:
lo facciamo quando usiamo
la stessa password dappertutto,
oppure quando, se riceviamo una mail
che sappiamo che non è per noi,
perché magari contiene una fattura
di un servizio che noi non abbiamo,
noi lo apriamo lo stesso quell’allegato,
anche se magari abbiamo
un avviso nel computer
che ci dice “Attenzione, questo allegato
potrebbe danneggiare il tuo computer”.
Noi siamo curiosi,
vogliamo vederlo e lo apriamo.
Tendiamo a sottovalutare dei rischi,
che però hanno un nome
e cognome ben preciso.
Il cyber crime è un fenomeno
che ogni anno movimenta qualcosa
come 1,5 trilioni di dollari:
è una cifra altissima,
una cifra che è pari più o meno
al PIL della Russia, per farvi capire.
È una vera e propria economia,
un'economia che cresce continuamente,
un'economia che si evolve.
Questa economia vive
grazie a degli attori
che sono i cyber criminali,
che hanno capito che la tecnologia
poteva essere sfruttata a loro vantaggio:
potevano portare quelle che erano
delle truffe e degli atti criminali
che facevano nella vita reale
all'interno della vita digitale.
Quindi hanno iniziato a studiare,
si sono organizzati,
hanno affinato delle tecniche
sempre più complesse
per colpire l'anello debole
della catena: la persona.
Per capire meglio questa evoluzione,
facciamo un passo indietro.
Trent'anni fa, Internet era
una rete ancora agli albori:
il primo sito web
è stato pubblicato nel 1993.
In questa rete agli albori,
c'erano solo poche persone
che la frequentavano,
principalmente ricercatori,
professionisti del settore
e nerd, persone che come me passavano
giornate intere collegate alla rete
per scoprire cose nuove,
per imparare, per sperimentare.
Ecco, in questo periodo
non si può parlare di cybercrime
organizzato come lo è oggi,
però le prime violazioni
informatiche c'erano.
Erano per lo più però a scopo
di divertimento, di dimostrazione:
c'erano i ragazzini che “bucavano”
i computer in giro per il mondo
perché poi si collegavano
alla chat con gli amici
e facevano vedere che erano connessi
da un computer
di un'università australiana,
o da un computer di una rete
governativa americana.
Facevano a gara a chi era più bravo.
Poi c'erano quelli
che scrivevano i primi trojan,
dei programmi che erano
dei veri e propri cavalli di troia
che una volta installati
nel computer della vittima
ti permettevano di controllarlo
totalmente da remoto.
Tu vedevi quello che loro
vedevano sullo schermo,
potevi spostare la freccia del mouse,
potevi aprire e chiudere
il cassettino del lettore CD.
Vi lascio immaginare
che scherzi si facevano all'epoca!
La cosa più interessante
era riuscire a convincere le persone
a installare questi programmi.
Si utilizzavano quelle tecniche
che oggi noi definiamo ingegneria sociale.
Che cos'è l'ingegneria sociale?
L’ingegneria sociale è appunto
un insieme di tecniche,
che fanno leva anche
sulla psicologia della persona,
per convincerla a fare
qualcosa con l'inganno,
che va a nostro vantaggio
e a suo svantaggio,
senza che questa se ne renda conto.
L'ingegneria sociale
è una delle tecniche più utilizzate
e sfruttate anche dal cyber crime.
Passano gli anni
e cambia un po’ lo scenario:
verso fine anni '90
Internet è diventato ormai una rete
di centinaia di milioni
di computer sempre connessi,
dove il browser e la posta elettronica
sono i due strumenti principali
per interfacciarsi con la rete.
Soprattutto, la posta elettronica
diventa uno strumento
che ti permette di raggiungere
moltissime persone in tutto il mondo
in maniera molto semplice e veloce,
quindi è un ottimo strumento
per veicolare degli attacchi
su larga scala.
In questo periodo infatti
si ricorda uno dei worm,
dei virus autoreplicanti,
che ha fatto un po’ la storia
per capacità e velocità di diffusione.
Questo virus ha sfruttato
la posta elettronica per diffondersi
e la curiosità delle persone
come fattore di successo.
Questo virus,
che si chiamava “I love you”,
è stato inventato da una persona
che l'ha nascosto all'interno
di un allegato di una mail
e ha scritto che all'interno
di questo allegato
ci sarebbe stata una lettera d'amore
da parte di un ammiratore segreto.
Questo è bastato per far scoppiare
una mania irrefrenabile da clic
in tutti i destinatari della mail.
Ogni persona voleva sapere
chi aveva scritto quella lettera d'amore,
quindi è stata sfruttata
questa tecnica di ingegneria sociale
per convincere le persone
e aiutarle nel diffondere questo virus.
Se noi prendiamo un parametro
che oggi conosciamo tutti,
l'indice RT che aveva “I love you”
era più o meno pari a 50.
Noi oggi ci preoccupiamo
quando supera l’uno!
Ecco che il cyber crime,
che sta studiando
l'evoluzione tecnologica,
capisce che la posta elettronica
è un ottimo strumento da utilizzare
per veicolare questi attacchi
e sfruttare le persone.
E così a inizio anni 2000
prendono piede quelle che sono
le famose truffe via mail,
che colpiscono la persona
nella sua individualità.
La classica truffa “alla nigeriana”,
la mail che sicuramente
tutti voi avete ricevuto
almeno una volta nella vita,
ad esempio quella del sedicente
principe nigeriano
che ha ricevuto una grossa eredità
che è bloccata per questioni burocratiche
e ha bisogno proprio
del vostro aiuto per sbloccarla.
Vi chiede una piccola somma di denaro
per fare le questioni burocratiche,
poi promette di condividere
con voi l'eredità.
La più classica delle truffe,
che poi però colpiscono l'individuo
anche nella sua sfera lavorativa.
Nasce quello che è il fenomeno delle BEC,
della business e-mail compromise,
quindi la compromissione
di comunicazioni di posta elettronica
che avvengono all'interno di un'azienda.
I cyber criminali
hanno studiato, hanno imparato,
hanno affinato delle tecniche nuove,
per cui riescono a spiare
le vostre conversazioni
e inserirsi proprio nel momento giusto,
quando magari vi scambiate
i dettagli di pagamento,
l’IBAN,
e mettono il loro,
così il bonifico arriva a loro!
In Italia è successo per esempio
che una società di calcio, la Lazio,
nel comprare un giocatore
ha versato l'ultima rata
a un cyber criminale,
per due milioni di euro.
Ecco che il cyber crime ha capito
che l'azienda è il target migliore,
perché gli permette di fare
guadagni facili e veloci molto elevati
e quindi verso metà anni 2000
nasce il fenomeno dei ransomware.
L'azienda, in piena digitalizzazione,
sta spostando i suoi processi
all'interno dell'informatica
e si lega a doppio filo con l'informatica,
però scopre questo nuovo rischio.
Che cos'è il ransomware?
Immaginate di arrivare
la mattina in ufficio,
accendere il pc,
aprire la posta elettronica
e questa non funziona.
Allora dite: “Vabbè, apro il documento
che stavo scrivendo ieri, così continuo”
e non si apre.
Provate ad aprire altri programmi,
ma non si apre nulla.
Tutti i dati dell'azienda
sono stati presi in ostaggio
da cyber criminali,
che vi stanno chiedendo
un riscatto per ridarveli
e magari vi stanno anche minacciando
che una parte di questi dati
la pubblicheranno, se voi non pagate.
Anche questo è un rischio
che mette in seria difficoltà le aziende:
qualche mese fa,
un fornitore di Apple, Quanta,
ha subito un attacco ransomware
e gli è stato chiesto un riscatto
di 50 milioni di dollari
se non voleva che questi dati sottratti
venissero pubblicati.
All'interno di questi dati,
c'erano anche design di prodotti Apple
che non erano ancora usciti nel mercato.
Capite che le aziende
sono prese per il collo
da questa situazione,
da questi cyber criminali.
Si trovano addirittura a non lavorare,
sono costrette a lasciare
la gente a casa in cassa integrazione,
perché non riescono proprio
a lavorare senza i loro dati.
I cyber criminali che le stanno attaccando
non sono più quelli di 10 anni prima,
che mandavano la mail di truffa nigeriana:
sono dei cyber criminali
che si sono organizzati
e che hanno costituito
delle vere e proprie organizzazioni
fatte da tante persone,
dove ognuno ha un ruolo ben preciso.
C'è chi individua le vittime
e chi le attacca,
chi mantiene le comunicazioni
con le sue vittime
e anche chi decide qual è il riscatto,
e quanto è eventualmente trattabile,
[Il boss].
Questo è un business
che nell'ultimo anno ha generato
un fatturato di un miliardo di dollari.
Capite che non ci si confronta più
con un fenomeno isolato.
A un certo punto, quando si è visto
che questi attacchi erano in grado
di paralizzare un'azienda
e chi li faceva iniziava
sfruttando sempre le persone,
magari che aprivano un allegato
che non dovevano aprire
o che mettevano la password
su un sito che non dovevano visitare,
però poi all'interno dell'azienda,
prima di compiere l'attacco
vero e proprio,
avevano delle competenze
veramente elevate.
A un certo punto
anche i governi hanno capito
che avrebbero potuto sfruttare questa cosa
ed è nato quello che oggi si chiama
cyber warfare, la guerra cibernetica:
è la guerra che si combatte
in un quinto dominio di conflittualità,
che è il cyber spazio,
che è stato ufficialmente
riconosciuto dalla NATO nel 2016.
All'interno di questo dominio,
ogni governo ha il suo esercito,
la sua unità cyber,
che fa attacchi di tipo cyber.
Nel 2010, gli Stati Uniti
hanno organizzato un'operazione cyber
insieme ad Israele contro l'Iran.
Dovevano mettere fuori uso
una centrale nucleare israeliana
e lo dovevano fare perché politicamente
non riuscivano a fermare
la rincorsa nucleare dell'Iran.
Così hanno ideato un virus
in grado di distruggere le centrifughe
della centrale nucleare iraniana.
Il problema era come portare
questo virus all'interno.
A voi sembra difficile
anche fare questo virus;
ma in realtà per loro
è stato molto semplice.
Per portarla all'interno
hanno sfruttato l’ingegneria sociale:
l’hanno messo all'interno
di alcune chiavette USB,
e le hanno abbandonate nel parcheggio,
perché sapevano che prima o dopo
qualcuno le avrebbe raccolte
e le avrebbe collegate
nei sistemi della centrale,
perché era curioso
di scoprire cosa c'era dentro.
Infatti, così è stato!
Quindi vi ho descritto
una serie di scenari:
alcuni secondo me possono sembrarvi
anche ai limiti della realtà,
quasi surreali, quasi kafkiani,
però in realtà sono tutti scenari reali,
che vi danno una chiara percezione
di quelli che sono i rischi
che potete trovarvi ad affrontare
vivendo la vostra vita digitale.
Ecco, voi oggi avete
un vantaggio, rispetto a ieri:
avete iniziato a prendere coscienza
di quali sono i rischi che si corrono
vivendo una vita digitale.
Avere chiaro lo scenario delle minacce,
quello che noi chiamiamo Threat Modeling,
è la vostra arma in più,
è il primo passo per capire
come dovete comportarvi,
cosa dovete fare per rendere
inoffensivo l'attaccante,
cosa dovete fare per proteggere
la vostra vita digitale.
Io sono convinto che oggi voi,
quando uscirete da qui
e quando vi troverete di nuovo
in una situazione
di dover fare un bonifico,
di dover aprire un allegato di posta,
di dover cambiare una password,
sono convinto che ci penserete due volte
e sono convinto che farete
la scelta giusta.